>>Mary Jean: Ontario is an
incredibly diverse province.
And so if our goal is going to be
to improve student achievement,
so our children will grow into
successful and happy adults,
we need to deal with that diversity.
And so it's not seen as a barrier,
it's seen as an opportunity
and a challenge.
>>Avis: From the outset,
we agreed that we had
to have special interventions
in place
in order to bring the bottom up.
The students who traditionally
had not done well.
>>Pat: So are you going
to join our sports teams?
>>Student: Yeah, I will.
>>Pat: And what's your
favorite sport?
>>Student: Track and field.
>>Pat: Oh, track and field; Oh, yeah,
we have a great track and field.
But that's not till this spring,
are you going to play
something in-between?
>>Susan: A lot of the
students that do come new
to the country have a variety of
needs and that may be academic,
it may be social, it
may be language-based.
it may be family-based, it
could be just survival skills.
You know, "How do I get transit?
Where is extra help available?"
And a student's success person
is a critical piece in a school
to help support that child.
>>Pat: Okay, how far did you get?
Did you get to the end of the book.
>>Student: Almost.
>>Pat: Okay, what's happened
since I read with you?
>>Pat: Students that are new to
Canada, there's a large transition.
The expectation is
that they read quickly.
That they process in English, and
that they can make inferences.
And those are skills
they may not have learned
in their own schooling system.
So we work with students
to bridge that gap.
>>Pat: Semester 1,
he has Period 1 off.
he has art Period 2.
He is good at strings.
His music mark is good.
So he will also get a
credit after school.
>>Pat: We have weekly meetings.
It brings our team
together, and it allow us
to track the students
that we are watching.
>>Teacher: Would a
support for him be--
there's going to be a new drama
class created, and it's going
to be a nine/ten split drama.
That might be a good place for
him to acquire some language.
>>Susan: Generally, the entire
school staff needs to be involved.
This is a collaborative effort.
Although, one person has the time
dedicated towards making sure it all
comes together, really it
is a full-school initiative.
>>Pat: We've been working in Success
with Janice since she was in Grade 9.
She came on her own.
She came from Hong Kong.
>>Susan: Some students
come across the table,
they're failing all four subjects.
They don't have money
for a transit pass.
They're living with no
parents in the country.
Their parents might
be living in China.
>>Pat: Last year, Dave and
I worked with the family
to move the guardianship
to another family.
She wasn't progressing
well without family.
She was not even allowed to
stay after school to see me.
Mm hm.
>>Susan: And that team
will network everything
from the cultural settlement
worker to the administrator to say,
an Alt. Ed. teacher,
to make connections and set
up that program for success.
That's the best example of a student
success team is looking at the child,
and looking holistically
how we can support them.
>>Pat: It's funny they say,
"I actually felt awake."
So maybe she-- this was
something new to me?
Mornings look a lot better
after nine hours of sleep.
>>Pat: The one-on-one
that's needed for some kids
to be successful can't be done when
you have another job happening.
You can't sit and take the
time to read with a student.
And they really need that extra time.
We don't want to be seen
as a disciplinarian.
When I introduce myself to the
new staff this year, I said,
"Don't use me as a threat."
Even my room, it doesn't
look like a classroom.
I didn't put desks in it.
I didn't want desks.
If it's an uncomfortable environment,
they're not going to come
after school for help or on their
lunch hour if it's more school.
So they may sit in a chair and read
their book that they're behind in,
because they get to sit
in a comfortable chair.
>>Mary Jean: We're succeeding!
In the five or six years that
we've been working at this,
the performance gap for our
new English-language learners
in this province has been closed
by about half of that gap.
And that's absolutely critical in
a province where up to 40 percent
of our children are, in fact, coming
from places outside of our province.